alors est-ce que vous êtes prêts pour le
fameux blind test n'est absolument
y a que des filles est à créditer
l'impression de reconnaître un mec qui a
quitté le bourg est d'accord alors on y
va corti
mais un constat il ya des tonnes je
n'aime pas les plus gros match en deux
parties
on est une femme et moi je croyais à
commettre ce choix que je suis quand
même a eu une bonne dizaine de
centimètres que wrangler me suis
construit mais tout de suite un soin
maniaque de nos talons ballina écoute
dans la troisième dimension souffrait
dans la première bosse souvent ça ton
coeur ces prestations ne manquerez
guinée des cours de tango
la motion qui sera capable il
s'intéresse à d'autres
joseph et des constantes changera les
choses du bon côté de créer une bonne
chanson you came c'est bien moi je pars
au lycée lyautey on va te demander voilà
voilà
on continue à la trouver
la t 30 call to london c'est dur de se
dire qu'on les poussait six ans et moi
il ya la zone de france gall qui
s'adorent ses danseuses et je connais
par coeur et sait found de dire j'adore
d'infos depuis depuis a que moi c'est
pêche continuent à trouver qu'elle est
là elle a un truc dans la joie à la
décharge continue mais de prendre le
chemin du roy c'est un col bleu ça fait
peur
m
non
mondeville écoute ça ne me regarde pas
les rondelles
ouais
la chanter non non non non ça c'est et
c'est vraiment pour adrian jacobs c'est
après plein de ça ça j'ai trouvé ça pas
bien les vaches l'un des raids a dit on
m'a fait faire des conneries c'est
veulent affronter choisi six arrêtés par
le rythme bien continuer sur un nul
souffle palio tu as trouvé de tétouan
via
elle dit qu'elle entend pas viable c'est
bien ici de la brouille vient d'ailleurs
à mon avis oui mais quel match
je sais pas c'est quoi le bonheur semble
toujours connu
pourquoi elle fait peur tu l'as lu dans
des conditions du nom allemand toute
cette faune mais elles m'ont tout à fait
la couverture de télé 7 jours c'est la
grande peur et niall mais écoute moi je
suis pas sûr
tu la vois tout le temps et les jeunes à
papa d'amy l'époque où l'actuel après
mon corps ne s'est pas beaucoup les
jeunes de toiture moi je crois pas mais
pas sur de bonnes copines quand on n'est
pas trop fine du tout on est on est
juste je ne sais pas les documents aux
soli choeur et oui mais moi j'ai des
copines d'école et je pense que j'aime
bien la fois
c'est plus calme toute façon l atalanta
beaucoup saison suivante
voilà qu'aujourd'hui on continue encore
floues
c'est bien une occasion saluer les
médias des modèles renault mais il a été
annulé
c'est une petite fille j'ai 14 ans et
qui fuit quand même des meilleurs
chevaux 4 mauvaise élégant pour la suite
non non vous n'êtes pas boire à l'époque
c'est dur de m'arrêter ya des gens qui
font qu'aller de mieux alors vous êtes
paul écoute bien ouais mais ici à
sédhiou tarbes avec punch et la vive
allure au caire des deux ce qui va lui
dise elle est celui qui faisait là comme
ça vient des gens c'est juste là bas les
instruments dans les oreilles et ishak
d'avoir ses grands mais c'est plus
encore des 2 100 blagues en ligne ou que
fait john lui même comme salis par
pauline par paul c'est insensé quoi
assurer sa nouvelle